one for my mother and father it's all  about pushing your boundaries and taking  risks in your own life you know Selma  was a narrative film then I changed it  up and made a doc in 13th we were like  wow you make talks now then you make  sell them in 13th there around criminal  justice you're like you know what I'm  gonna make a movie a fantasy movie for  children right and after that who knows  what I'll to do but you have to keep  pushing yourself it's so easy in this  world to put yourself in the box that  the world wants you to be in the  industry wants you to be in that your  family want you to be in society want  you to be in push against it and and  keep moving forward on your own path and  that's what I've tried to do that's what  she's doing that's what you've done and  that's what we have to try to do  [Music]